[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they actually love
and create real
amazing
this is a show about your life we're
glad you're here ken coleman ramsey
personality of the ken coleman show
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today if you haven't heard the
ken coleman show it's all about your
work and your career and uh getting into
work you love and actually making money
you do it and all that kind of stuff so
he's here to help me today and we're
gonna talk to you about your life and
your money the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll start with ben in tampa florida
hey ben how are you
hey i'm doing great how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well first of all thanks for taking my
call um so we have a
mortgage
new construction
house related question
so we
sold our house in
december of 21
and we made luca amount of money on it
and
we went under contract for a new build
um literally within a couple weeks
in december as well
obviously we did the whole
debt to income ratio
we wanted to be in that 35 36 percent to
be comfortable
with this new mortgage and
now that the
the rates have obviously almost doubled
since december 21
and we couldn't foresee that but i would
just like to know what
my options are and if you have any
details on
what i think you're going to say what
one option is
but again we're just pretty nervous
about
being up to probably 50 percent
death income uh
with the new mortgage um potentially on
the horizon
outlook taxes and also hoas and
well bent ben
you're apparently fairly new to our
material we appreciate you joining us
um we teach people to never do anything
over 25 percent of your take-home pay
not 36 36
max
you bought the most that they would
possibly qualify you for
and then
you probably don't even qualify now
they don't qualify for you can't qualify
for a mortgage of 50 of your income
well so yeah we're pretty close i would
say we're about 47 right now yeah
that's suicide
absolute suicide
yeah what you did was dumb to start with
it's gone from dumb over into crazy
yeah
but
let me tell you let me tell you why i
say that and then you understand why i'm
being so dramatic
okay
here's the thing that's okay there's two
elements
that the size of your mortgage affect
number one uh the first thing it affects
is when you have much more than 25
of your household take-home pay going
into your debt into your mortgage you
don't have any wiggle room left in your
budget and it tends to drive people into
debt they don't save to buy their next
car they go into debt to buy their next
car they don't save for vacation they go
into debt to go on vacation they don't
save for christmas they go into debt for
christmas all because they're what we
call house poor
and they can't win at 50 of your
take-home pay it's virtually impossible
to operate the household without going
deeply into debt on the other items
there's just no room in your budget i've
been doing budgets for 35 years with
individuals okay when 50 percent of your
income goes out to your house payment
that's called house poor
you got nothing left
you are stressed looking for a place to
happen you are going to learn to hate
this house and your spouse by the time
you get out of this you all are going to
be fighting about money all the time
there's going to be stress dripping off
the place all that the second problem is
this
further out there than the short-term
problems that i just outlined
is the number
no there's two main things that happens
to people that become millionaires
they
put money into their 401k and their roth
ira on a steady diet
and
they pay off their home
you can do neither
when you're at 50 percent
so is this contract for this builds
contingent upon financing
it is
good
good you're going to be moving somewhere
else young man if you're smart
you do whatever you want to do but if
you call me up and you're my best friend
my little brother my son that's exactly
what i would tell you
because it it's it's going to break your
heart it's going to break your wife's
heart y'all are going to be it's going
to break the builder's heart it's going
to break everybody so everybody's little
heart's going to be broken let me tell
you what you choose your pain you're
either going to choose a pain in the
short term right now to get out of this
mess and go get something you can afford
or
you're going to choose the pain long
term of you're going to walk with a
financial limp for the next decade with
this
so you don't see any
let the let it all calm down and think
about refinancing just fight the bullet
for the next year or two
and refinance maybe well i mean yeah if
the rate came back down and you could
refinance or if you have the potential
to double your income in the next three
years
to where you would get to 25 percent of
your take-home pay
you know you can do it for a period of
time
but the problem is you're stressing
the machine you're like running you got
your foot on the accelerator and you're
running this car at like six thousand
r's
seven thousand hours you're up in the
red on the rs you follow me
and you can you can run down the street
that way i mean you run 10 miles that
way but you try to run 100 miles with
that thing you can blow that engine
and that's what we're talking about here
you're redlining
hey ben it sounds to me like everything
dave has laid out you you either expect
him to say or you agree with it but
you're feeling some pressure from
somewhere else maybe someone else is
that true or false
um i would say it's partly true because
uh uh the decision to do this was to
make our forever home we needed a bigger
place to be for our teenager his friends
and it gave us an opportunity to be
completely debt free except the house
yeah i'm hearing that i'm hearing you
completely agree with everything dave
said and yet you're still hanging on but
but but and dave i think that's the real
challenge here there's some personal
stuff going on in that whole family unit
that's making him try to find a way that
really isn't there and you're trying to
do something good for your family yeah
and you're gonna do it in such a way
that's gonna be bad for your family
and when you when you emotionally digest
that as well as intellectually digest
that and you and your wife as two grown
ups sit and look at this and go we're
not in congress
we have to live on less than we make
this is not a good 10-year plan this is
not a good 20-year plan and therefore
it's not good for your teenager because
teenagers absorb stress off their
parents
like sponges
if your family starts tightening up and
can't breathe and then you and your wife
start going at each other which the
number one cause of marital disagreement
and divorce is money stress and money
problems and you're just walking
straight into the bandsaw you're walking
right into the flamethrower you are
asking for it
you know i just wouldn't advise that to
anybody i loved i love you man i want
you to win i don't want you to i'm not
here to keep you from having nice things
i'm here to keep your nice things from
having you
and that's what we want you to do so you
do whatever you want but we called in
here and we're experts on our opinion
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today new york
city's on the line sarah's with us hi
sarah how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
all right so my husband and i are having
a baby in september
and we're disagreeing about whether or
not we should be buying a new task car
to
prepare um we currently have a 98 honda
accord and a 2008 toyota rav4
um i'm not really comfortable with the
idea of the baby being in the 98 all the
safety changes you know in the past
20 plus years
so we have no debt we make a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars a year before
taxes we have forty thousand dollars
outside of our emergency fund
um my husband acknowledges that we can
afford the car but doesn't want to buy
it because it's a want not a need it's a
bad time to be buying cars and there's
nothing wrong with the 98
i think we're ready for an upgrade
so what do you think can i or
better yet you tell him that it's time
to crack open his wallet
is he listening great you're awesome we
should sell tickets i think we should
sell tickets this is great
he's outside the room dave he's standing
with baited breath
[Laughter]
and he let you set all of this up just
to have his head taken off this is
awesome yes he did give me his arguments
before i called
his financial arguments are all accurate
um but there are some things beyond the
financial argument your argument on
safety is absolute bs it's absolutely
not true
okay you're talking to an old man that
grew up we wrote in the back window of
the car and when they slammed on the
brakes it threw us into the floorboards
so your baby's gonna survive okay so
it's gonna be okay you're gonna be all
right but
you can afford a car
so it is a want and you have the money
for the want it is not a need and
there's never been a car well except for
classic cars that are collectibles that
is a good investment they all go down in
value they're all mathematically
horrible
okay so it's just simply consumption but
you make how much a hundred and sixty
thousand a year
180
before taxes yeah sorry 180 okay that's
after tax
before tax oh before tax 180 right okay
so what you said all right and you have
forty thousand dollars allocated to the
car
and uh you don't have any debt right
yeah okay
so uh you if you pay cash for the car
uh yes you should move up in car no you
should not buy a brand new car unless
you have a net worth of a million
dollars or more
in which case if you want to buy a new
car you can't hard to find one for 40
but these days but you can do that
so but yeah i think you would move up in
car and uh you might move up in two cars
i'm okay neither one of these cars yeah
neither one of these cars
but as long as you're paying cash and
the total that you're investing in them
is less than half of your annual income
and it would be
you know you wouldn't have the cash to
do more so um
you know but if you moved up uh 15 000
each in two different cars you would
move into substantially different
vehicles
um
and
you we could just set the whole baby
thing aside except that that your
pregnancy is what caused the argument
but
you just without a baby involved you
could still do this deal
it's not unreasonable financially
okay okay so you win the argument but
for none of the reasons that you thought
now sarah
sarah relationally i feel like i got to
speak up on behalf of your husband now
when you share this with him you got to
read him so maybe the win for you
relationally
with him is that you give him your car
instead of buying two cars that may be
too much for him to handle i don't know
dave this guy's on the other side of the
wall
ken is saying
that doesn't work to bring this up yes
i'm basically going uh i tell you what
we could just upgrade my car and i'll
give you
uh the one that i'm driving uh or maybe
if he wants you know you know the truth
is that his arguments financially are
all correct yeah
there's there's almost no time you can
justify
moving up in car financially
it almost never makes sense financially
oh it breaks down all the time it
doesn't break down as much as 15 000
which we're talking about moving up on
one car here right you know fifteen
thousand dollars in repairs that's
absolute bs and the safety of a honda
accord this one is just fine you're just
fine just don't drive like a maniac yeah
but you know it's not a james bond movie
you're in you're just taking a kid to
daycare so um but the uh you know so
yeah but uh
but the truth is it's a luxury
that is not going to [ __ ] you
financially that you can afford
and i do some stuff like that and i'm
freaking dave ramsey which is kind of
synonymous with tight watts so
um you know i i sharon and i buy some
things that we can afford
and uh they don't meaning they can't
they don't [ __ ] us financially they
don't slow us down financially it's a
small enough number that it doesn't
matter and all of these numbers
fall in that category i'll tell you one
your coffee maker at the lake i have no
idea what it costs nobody's business but
that's a fantastic coffee maker but i
got to tell you at the lake house very
fancy i was intimidated
[Laughter]
but i had some cheap cars but yeah i
mean
it's not a 15 000 coffee maker but yeah
it's a nice coffee maker is all i'm
saying and it's just you know it falls
under the category of sws sharon wants
it i like that that's a good category we
can uh and in this case uh sarah wants
it swi right
so that would make great reality tv the
rest of this conversation see we put
sarah on hold now she's going to go talk
to the hubs who's behind the wall
watching how that goes
i told you so it's not going to be a
great line here but the uh because you
for all the reasons she wanted to do it
she was wrong
that's true the only reason it works is
because it works and you can afford it
and so if you want to buy an item
that doesn't make sense financially but
you have the money now here's another
way to look at having the money i often
use this on the air and i'll use it with
this case okay cars are the same way
if you take that amount of money and set
fire to it yes
just to watch it burn
does it hold you back substantially
financially does it cause you to walk
with a limp financially does it cause
you to be you know to be off your kilter
and if the answer is no then you can
afford yeah the luxury of it but
oftentimes people buy something and they
justify their butts off they rationalize
their butts off and it's something you
really that's the amount of money you
can't afford to burn up correct i mean
if you make sixty thousand dollars a
year and you wanna go buy a forty
thousand dollar car you can't afford to
burn that much money yeah it'll burn
your hair off i mean you can't do it
right and so that that's what the type
of way you're looking at is you go does
this change my life if i burn this much
money then you go well then i can afford
to buy the luxury or you know like james
he collects he collects uh 25 000
guitars right and i just made that up
but he doesn't like he has he's just
choked he does have way too many guitars
there's a lot of guitars represented in
the booth as a matter of fact right now
that's true a lot of stringed
instruments are represented in the booth
can they afford those given that none of
them make their living with those
instruments
yes they can right because that amount
of money as a luxury or in a hobby is
something i care about yeah doesn't
there's something they care about yeah i
don't but they that that's
i mean if i buy this gu if i buy another
gun
like i don't have enough i got plenty if
i buy another one which i'm out to do at
any moment yeah does it change my
financial trajectory no yeah and as long
as that's the answer and if my wife buys
a purse no one should spin yet on a
purse you're right they shouldn't but
people do including her
and so
yeah now when she's spinning that on
again
let me tell you what the let me tell you
what guns cost you two purses i was
getting ready to ask that you get a new
gun sharon gets a couple purses that's
good it's a trade out it's a trailer
same same with james and his guitars
right yeah by the way when dave says he
has a lot of guns if the tennessee
tennessee national guard had a shortage
you're on speed dial i know i'm gonna
someday i'm gonna be arrested as a as an
insurgent
but the uh i'm not sure against what
you're going to give people ideas
they've been looking for an end for you
there it is see you're easy they've been
looking for a way to get you but the
point being if you're spending money on
something that has absolutely no
uh
benefit except it's something you want
you lit you have lived like no one else
so now you can live right and give like
no one else same thing about giving
money away
when you're being generous with the
money you should be able to give it away
and it not change your life except for
the huge benefit that being a generous
person gives you
it's the same exact process
so but if you want to give everything
you own away please stop and think about
that one that needs to be god's voice in
your ear for sure not some kind of guilt
trip by a liberal
this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
officially on the debt free stage is
adam and
lonnie laney laney i knew i was going to
mess that up laney welcome you guys
where do you live
we live in hudsonville michigan which is
just outside of grand rapids very cool
great area we love grand rapids been
been a wonderful relationship with the
ramsey team up there over the years all
right well how much debt did you two pay
off we paid off a hundred and forty
thousand seven hundred and seventy one
dollars
excellent how long did that take took 30
months wow and your range of income
during that time 150 to 170. cool what
do you all do for a living
i am an engineering manager
i am a special education teacher for
autism awesome very cool what kind of
debt was your 141 000
so
11 740 was a home equity line of credit
for a vehicle for a car
and then 129 thousand 31 dollars was our
house you paid off
we did i know we're looking at weird
people yes yes you are way to go guys we
were we were hoping that you'd call us
weird oh it's it's a standard thing man
normal's broke weird people are not
broke that's good it's weird to actually
be out of debt and have some money way
to go you two
excellent excellent excellent all right
what's this house worth
it's worth like 400.
how much in your retirement accounts
uh right around 450. okay bumping up
next to millionaire then huh working on
it all right going to be baby steps
millionaires before we know it how old
are you two
you can go first i'm 39 almost 40. and
i'm 38. all right not even 40 and you're
almost millionaires and 100 percent
debt-free
you guys are amazing i'm so proud of you
thank you there you go oh man it's
surreal to be here way to go
all right well tell us your story what
in the world happened two and a half
years ago set you guys on fire uh i mean
we we had done some things right with
money but not everything for sure and in
the beginning of 2020
new year's resolution style
uh done a lot of listening to you and
then
really just started talking to laney and
we talked about where we wanted to go
and one of the things that really
unlocked things for us was
sharing the budget and using every
dollar so that there was visibility
i'm being an engineer i keep track of
things pretty closely and always had
good intent of sharing that and you know
we'd have a monthly reminder on the
calendar to sit down but unfortunately
it just wouldn't happen and so every
every dollar just unlocked things for us
so that there was
instantaneous visibility and we both
knew where we were at yeah it's really
helpful like adam said he's phenomenal
with creating a budget and he's got
awesome excel spreadsheets and
everything and i look at it and i'm like
yeah and then every dollar he gets way
too much joy from this doesn't he does
[Laughter]
one of the things that got me most fired
up is i had a normal armorization table
of our mortgage and then every single
time we paid extra just ratcheted down
yeah and you got down right you could
see yourself just knocking out months
and months and years that that is
powerful that's uh uh
that math blows your mind when you first
see it you go i'm gonna slide down that
many months but a thousand i'm gonna
find another 50 bucks so i get to that
other month you know it's just it's
crazy way to go y'all way to go how does
it feel to have no payments in the world
weird
oh it's just a such such a great feeling
such a great feeling for our family uh
one of the main reasons we're here is is
for those two little guys over there
they are crazy and that's our family but
it's who we are
and it was funny when we were talking
about coming on the show uh i just kept
reminding lainey like let's just be
ourselves to be ourselves this is who we
are yeah right and we're we're real
people that live in michigan and
and just want to spread hope to other
people too i love that i don't want to
stay on that theme you know laney you're
kind of talking about the spreadsheets
make your eyes roll around your head and
boy do i certainly you know identify
with that uh but i think it's great to
for for other couples that are listening
in watching to know how did you all make
it work with you all being so very
different what what made it work for you
all coming together with very different
personalities different strengths and so
forth yeah um
i mean i think we were definitely each
other's biggest cheerleaders and
we have great communication which helps
you really had a 90 and you just dialed
it up to 99 didn't you with the every
dollar budget yeah definitely
another thing that was neat that adam
did was um he took a house and he made
it into all these little squares for us
and so each time we made a payment to
the house there it is yeah so one of the
one of the house payoff graphics and so
that was that was powerful for us so
that and you can see that the boys
helped us color it in too so they
they were part of the experience we were
very open with them about what we were
doing and why we were doing it
and it's it's kind of funny there's a
funny story where it was actually the
day before cohen's birthday and grady
and i we were going into into granville
outside of grand rapids to pick up a
last minute birthday gift for him and we
saw a really nice car because one of the
things that we paid off was actually a
vehicle
and
later in our journey in november of last
year we actually decided that
it was a vehicle that we had had our fun
with it was a camaro and
and we decided that uh
reverse engineered it and said
based on car values because car values
just were just crazy it was like you
know what we're gonna let this one go
and did you actually make money on it uh
i did not but it was real close yeah
yeah i drove it for three years for free
for 1200 bucks yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty cool but i remember grady's
saying to me i i pointed out a nice car
because we're automobile people we like
cars and stuff and uh he was like well
when are we gonna get or why did we sell
our car and i was like well we put the
money towards the house and then right
away he asked me well how many squares
was that
so it was it connected and i was like
well it was like 60 squares and he's
like man that's a lot of squares yeah
that's good yeah yeah you have a whole
new currency in your house yeah i wear
squares yeah that's good every time your
theme song comes on the boys are like
it's dave's show
yeah just uh originally
listening to the radio um you're on
106.9 in grand rapids from six to nine
in the evenings and just happened stance
listening to that i remember there was
financial peace at our church years ago
and we knew very little about it then uh
didn't participate just heard people
talk about envelopes and stuff like that
and then
as it uh you know continued to be on our
hearts and as we learned more about it
then we were like well this is the plan
for us what do you tell people the key
to getting out of that issue
i think communication
and
prayer honestly i mean anytime something
came into our house that was extra we
would talk and we would pray about how
we wanted to tie first and and then we
continued
um how many squares is it right
yeah and then of course the boys i mean
there's something in your family whether
it's kids or each other or just yourself
like you deserve to live like you've
never lived before and so use that as
motivation
in your case changing your family tree
yeah well done yo all right let's bring
the boys up and introduce them uh what
are their names and ages this is grady
he is 10. and this is cohen and he is
eight cohen and grady very cool very
cool we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you our latest number
one bestseller around here how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth how
you can too you're almost there
millionaire status so you will see
pictures of yourself in here at least
statistically very well done and it's
because you're exactly what this book is
about also total money makeover for you
to give away and help someone else
that's inspired by your journey when
they hear about you and financial peace
university if you never took it you can
take it now it's the brand new videos
the best version of financial peace
university we've ever done this is a
one-year membership so we'll give you
that as well or you can give it away
whatever you want to do with it thank
you we're so glad you're here
congratulations you guys proud of you
thanks thank you very good stuff thanks
for coming all the way to nashville to
celebrate with us we love as i said we
love grand rapids people in that area
it's an absolutely incredible area and
uh we've had a
wonderful uh decades-long relationship
with that community so very very cool
all right it's adam and laney grady and
cohen from hutton hutsonville michigan
141 000 paid off in 30 months count it
down let's hear a debt free scream all
right you guys ready
three
two
[Applause]
that's how it's done
you want to know what that sound was
that was the sound of a family tree
changing right there you always wondered
what it sounded like didn't you
that's it this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today big announcement are you ready
our wealth building
live
building wealth live event tour
is completely blowing up
we sold out phoenix
for september 13th
sacramento minneapolis san antonio are
all in the 90
sold out bracket
so that means a handful of tickets are
available for those cities do not wait
if you're sitting around thinking about
joining us don't
wait it's going to be me and ken coleman
sitting to my right dr john deloney
george campbell rachel cruz we're going
to be there talking to you guys about
building wealth in this current
environment
how do you analyze what's going on in
the marketplace in the culture in the
economy and still
put yourself in a position to move
forward again phoenix september the 13th
sold out sacramento november the 1st
minneapolis november the 10th san
antonio november the 15th passes start
at five dollars you can get a four pack
starting at sixty dollars go to ramsey
solutions dot com slash events get your
seats these are going to be gone in just
a matter of days or maybe a week or two
something like that oh and we're gonna
help you out
we have not been able to secure any more
venues in any of the other cities but we
did secure
september the 12th in phoenix so we are
opening up a new night in phoenix if you
missed out on the first night september
the 12th added now that is a monday and
we would love to have you so brand new
it is obviously not sold out it goes on
sale today
so uh that's pretty cool phoenix is on
fire for ramsay stuff yeah two nights in
a row we love that market uh so listen
bring friends family if you can't get it
on the 13th we got another night and you
might like it so much on monday night
you just you know i mean you're just
gonna come back so you're just like i'm
anticipating it's gonna be so great i'm
gonna come to no monday night's the new
one no i don't know tuesday
tuesday i know cheers but if you already
bought your tuesday ticket don't create
a security problem coleman
sorry folks he doesn't like the off
script jokes it doesn't work
if they cause our security guys problems
yeah that is true it's gonna be fun
though it you know these events have all
been electric
a lot of people coming early every event
we've been to we're doing book signings
we're taking pictures we're hanging out
with you guys and hey we're so excited
just to be doing these things again yeah
we're just happy to be somewhere besides
nashville uh we love nashville too but
oh my gosh being able to travel on those
events in your city it's our favorite
thing to do is personalities so again
sacramento minneapolis san antonio just
a handful of tickets left phoenix
september 13th sold out today adding a
new one this one probably won't last a
month
uh so september 12th you know take a cue
from the fact the other one is gone and
get your tickets phoenix you can you can
now get in on that brand new date at
ramseysolutions.com
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer custom
window coverings with free samples
free shipping
and new promos all the time
to get the best deal on the promo always
use the magic word it is magic ramsey we
love blinds.com they love us we love
their customers they're you
this is the ramsay show all right kim
what do we got today's question is from
scott in michigan i have uh now been
leading fpu for several years so i'm
well versed on what the ramsey plan is
for a ton of life situations i now face
a dilemma
in my attempt to further my career i
have a lot of big banks mortgage
companies and other such financial
institutions at which i could work i'm
wondering is there a mo excuse me a
moral or ethical issue
with going to work for one of these
institutions since they make their money
by selling debt i'm in i.t so i wouldn't
have any direct involvement in the
business side but it still seems like it
would be a conflict of principle what
are your thoughts well scott in some
ways you answer your own question here
because while it is in fact a dilemma
because of what you believe how you live
your life and how you're teaching others
the ramsey way
this is a dilemma but it is not a moral
ethical issue
period end of end of sentence there's
nothing you're not breaking the law
uh you are not doing anything that would
even be considered a gray area from an
ethical standpoint however this is a
principal issue and so you've got
principle on one side
and
you've got a legitimate way to work
you're in i.t and you can make really
good money and do very well there but
this is not an ethical issue it is a
principal issue and that's a difference
and so you've got to be able to live
with you now there's no way let me give
you an example what i do on that okay
i endorse
community banks sure and credit unions
in a lot of cities right a lot of local
radio stations sell ads with my voice
that i endorse and i do believe in them
yeah in community banks and church hill
mortgage a mortgage churchill mortgage
and mike hardwick owns churchill's one
of my best friends yep
and uh so
now what's the difference i wouldn't
endorse bank of america
for any amount of money
i would feel dirty
so the way i answer the question is
would i send
someone there that i care about
because i'm getting ready send my
listeners there you guys out there
and if i if i would not send someone i
care about there then i don't need to
send anybody there that's hypocritical
what i do i t work
do you feel dirty when you get home
because of the way that business is
conducted who they are how they do
business the type of products they put
out the door so there's various kinds of
debt products
there's various kinds of banks
uh there are banks like bank of america
where you're a number all they see you
as an opportunity to loan you money sofi
all their all their soft pedaling uh
nurturing bullcrap at marketing is all
about just trying to make you feel
better about them trying to sell you
debt yeah and so i couldn't work for
them i couldn't i certainly wouldn't
endorse them obviously uh you know jp
morgan chase i'm not endorsing so i
don't endorse any big banks but i do
endorse small banks and i tell people
not to borrow money isn't that where
well you have a checking account there
you have some other things there you
could work in the mortgage business we
tell people not to take out a mortgage
unless it's more than a 15th year and if
you got the money to pay cash pay cash
and churchill mortgage goes along with
that so we endorse churchill mortgage
right and have for 25 years so i think
you're fine
uh where what it amounts to is are you
being hypocritical yes
and and the way you answer that is would
i send what i send my best friend there
i really like that that's the slime ball
test yeah if they're not a slime ball
then there's no issue you're fine go do
good i.t work if the you know i'm not
working for a payday lender they're
taking advantage of the poor
period and they're not going to be on
any on this show you know ever as long
as i'm breathing you know and that kind
of thing so that that's
you know but that that's uh
you you just
you're right it's morals
ethics and hypocrisy and it is kind of a
grady all the way to principles it is
kind of a gradient
there um you know if you work at pizza
hut and they take visa
yeah you know it doesn't mean that
you're for credit cards and you're
waiting tables are you
violating your financial piece uh when
you raised your right hand said i
promise to never do debt and never do
credit cards as long as i shall live or
whatever the boy scouts honor thing is
right that's right and so you know that
kind of thing hold three fingers
together put them up in the air all that
kind of stuff right so but i don't
borrow money
and so and i teach people this stuff so
if i took credit cards that would be
super bad
right that would be inconsistent i
remember i went to when i first started
this i went to a get out of debt seminar
this guy had and he sold a ton of books
on credit cards at the back table during
the break yeah and i'm like this is so
inconsistent that's correct
and so but uh we take debit cards here
and uh we we tell you not to use your
credit card you know it's hypocritical
we do not need your money if you're
borrowing money to buy our stuff do not
borrow money to buy our stuff that's
ridiculous it's you know the stuff's at
the library and you can listen on for
for free on youtube and on this show on
your local radio station so don't go
borrow money to do it if you want to
enhance the process and you have the
money by buying a book or going to
financial peace university here using
ken's assessment or reading one of his
books to enhance the process to get a
a thing but you don't need to go in debt
to get a job no no not at all and so
this comes down to again what do i
believe is right for me
versus right and wrong yeah if that's
the you got to do if i'm hardcore
financial peace university and i own a
restaurant is it bad for me to take
credit cards i don't think so no not at
all but if you're if you're me and you
make your living doing this that because
i tell people and then if i did that
would be that would be backward you know
so um it's now if you believe you're
bringing harm to someone and you're
doing that intentionally you in any
business or in any position in any
business if you believe you're
participating in that company doing bad
things
or something that's bad for people then
you're going to have a hard time
succeeding at that
it's uh because your your brain is
called cognitive dissonance your brain
works against itself
so don't try to do that
i don't care how much money you make
doing scummy things doesn't pay off
psychologically in the long run that's
what it comes down to it's a great
question what a great heart he's got
good stuff ken coleman
thanks for joining me this hourglass
show
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show where he talks about
careers and jobs and you getting one you
love is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five michael's gonna start us
off in iowa hey michael how are you
wonderful how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so my question is as
you're helping people in their financial
journey and becoming debt free
when you get to that point that you're
financially free from any
and you have
children that are in the house i
understand that
you know
instilling the values that
you
you know don't use debt in your everyday
life and
you know
when you get to that point and you're
still having you know younger kids at
home
how do you
[Music]
how did you do it with your children so
that way you know as they
moved out of the house
they weren't
feeling entitled or
you know oh you know mom and dad have
money so
you know i can
basically use it's a great question
what they have so so how do you keep
becoming from becoming wealthy and it's
screwing up your kids
exactly like entitlement entitlement is
arrogance
it's i'm do something that i didn't earn
okay
you correct you can you can fix that
with kids regardless of the amount of
money in your house
okay so the ramsey kids growing up um
were entitlement was not something we
allowed and self-centered
self-centeredness was not something we
allowed and they're very similar
so a couple of things we did and i'm
gonna send you a copy of the number one
bestseller rachel and i did together
called smart money smart kids uh and so
there's a couple of items uh let's start
with a very uh
philosophical highbrow thing
contentment
is almost never around entitled people
contentment comes
from
gratitude
i'm thankful
lord thank you for what i have
and it helps you to be content in what
you have and so our children it was not
an option we trained them in their
gratitude muscle
thank you
please
yes sir
no sir yes ma'am no ma'am we're from the
south
you're gonna have you're gonna have
manners and you're going to uh you're
not going to
allow someone to
impose themselves across your boundaries
or do something evil or wrong to you
that's not what we're saying but thank
you
i'm sorry
verbal generosity
sets the table for the rest of this
discussion
and then the rest of the discussion and
it's all age-appropriate
okay but it does melt to grandpa's heart
when my two-year-old or
three-year-old is barely talking is
thank you papa
or maybe you can't even maybe it wasn't
even enunciated that well right uh you
know some baby talk version right but
thank you papa
it changes my whole life when that
happens right when i watch that because
that's gratitude and gratitude is what's
missing in entitled people
and so um
once you do that then we taught our kids
to do four basic things in the money
thing that were character issues we
built their muscle age appropriately
number one they learned to work
you don't have an option if you're a
ramsay you're going to work now we
didn't send three-year-olds to the salt
mines
okay it's age-appropriate
but when you're 16 and you're exhausted
because you've been in the backyard with
your old man cutting trees or cleaning
the furniture or whatever all day long
oh cry me a river
your butt's going to be out there in the
sun sweating like your old man doing
this stuff work physical labor is good
work that is mental that you're mentally
and emotionally exhausted when you're
through with there is dignity in work
there is no dignity in sloth
and so age appropriately intense
intensity increasing with age you had to
work if you're ramsey because that's
where money comes from
it doesn't come from the government i'm
sorry joe biden it doesn't come from you
i'm sorry donald trump it doesn't come
from you none of you have ever sent me
any of my any money except some of you
sent some of my money back to me
but none of you sent me any money that
wasn't already mine in the first place
because i'd already sent you more than
that
and so that's how that works now once
you learn to work then we had three
other muscles we need to build and
that's the muscle of generosity and
that's not only holding the door and
saying thank you and please
and putting the dishes in the dishwasher
for your mama because you say i love you
that way but the the generosity is also
you give money away
age appropriately oddly enough you don't
have to teach young children that they
will try to give too much away
they are much more generous than we
selfish adults are number two uh they
need to learn to
give save they need to save money
build a savings muscle learn to set a
goal learn to work towards a goal and
then number three spend wise spending
and people that can do all four of those
things when they leave home at 18 don't
ever move back into your basement
they work they save they give they spend
they're grateful they say please and
thank you and they mean it and they know
the axis of the world does not run
through the top of their entitled little
head
and they don't end up becoming activists
they actually get a job and produce
something for the culture
that's right
i i would just add one thing michael and
i'm in the middle of it right now with
three teams
and uh i i think we as parents need to
let our kids struggle more and what i
mean by that is put them in a place
where they must struggle and then allow
the struggle whether that be learning an
instrument
uh or a new job right because when
you're taking on a job with the first
time at 15 that's true you've got one in
football practice yes sir that's true i
think i think whether it's a sport or it
is some type of extracurricular activity
i interviewed malcolm gladwell about
this many many years ago
one of the great thinkers on the planet
and he essentially said this and what
happens is when we as parents
try to keep our kids from a place of
struggle then what happens is is they
begin to expect benefit or success
instead of appreciate it and it's much
like dave just said on the working part
but you know entitlement to me is when i
expect something not appreciate
something and struggle when you grow up
in a household like that or a household
like i grew up in or you grew up in if
we got triggered on something
there were no safe places no
no in fact we did actually
your butt was about to go to work
well you know to your point i would
never dream of getting triggered with my
dad no because i'm gonna tell you what
would have been triggered
because i could hear the leather belt
whistling through the belt loops as he
pulled it off
i'm talking about it
if you have a problem with something you
don't expect someone else to fix it or
to keep you safe yeah when you when you
survive struggle right and so that's the
thing but when you actually taste it and
feel it you go wait a second i
appreciate it when you have overcome
obstacles it builds character builds
muscle it builds confidence it builds
dignity
when they when no one has overcome a
struggle there's no dignity in their
life
hang on we'll send you a copy of smart
money smart kids and get you started on
that that's a great question thanks for
letting us get up on a soapbox
[Music]
we were drawn to christian health care
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is our
co-host today my co-host the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five jason's in boston
hi jason welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi ken how are you folks better
than we deserve sir how can we help
thank you um so my wife um she just
downloaded the app she's actually
listening at home so you're in a sense
talking to both of us at the same time
which is good cool um
so we um we just decided that we are
going to uh start the baby steps um and
with some unfortunate mishaps we've uh
we've fallen behind in some of our bills
and uh we don't have a one thousand
dollar emergency fund yet um so
where do we start what do we do wow
so what happened
uh well so my wife is a breast cancer
survivor
and
and our oldest son who helps contribute
to the house just lost his job and
and my hours were cut just a little bit
so we we've got a
just uh just a big financial mess and
mix that in with some poor spending
habits and
here we are yeah okay
well um there's
certainly we're going to put you guys
into financial peace university to help
you turn this around showing you how to
handle money and how to do a budget and
everything but it sounds to me like at
the core you've got a uh an income
crisis
more than anything i'll let ken address
that in just a second
as far as the baby steps go
your first goal before you start the
baby steps is get current
that may mean selling stuff it may mean
having a garage sale it may mean taking
extra jobs 16 of them
it may mean selling so much stuff the
kids think they're next
uh that kind of thing okay so i'm
talking radical because you gotta get
current fast
because this is such a tenuous
scary place to live your wife dealing
with medical problems and now dealing
with we can't even stay current on the
light bill it she it's terrorizing her
and i want i want you guys all
to get i i i
i don't need it but i'm saying for your
sake i've been where you are not on the
cancer part but on the broke part and it
just scares the crap out of you and to
get away from that level of terror and
fear is your first
order of business so getting current on
a budget
is first then start the baby steps and
doing anything you can in the short term
to get your income up and then the long
term to get your income up is next ken
yeah jason curious what do you do for a
living now
i i work for uh fedex okay and so d when
you say you had your hours cut how much
uh so they they cut me down like like a
day or two over the last uh
over the last couple of weeks uh but
that's going to be getting back up
as we as we continue towards the the end
of the summer here what are you making
over the course of a year last couple
years what do you make
uh i'm right around 70
between 70 and 75 000. yeah what are you
doing driving or loading
uh driving yeah okay what's the long
term for you have you thought about it
what would it look like up the ladder a
couple rungs doing what kind of work
um i actually enjoy what i'm doing um
and you know i
yeah what are you going to do on these
off days to create extra income then
that's more than you're making now
uh so in the even right now i'm i'm door
dashing and driving for lyft okay all
right good good
yeah i think that's good i would
challenge you though because of your uh
ability and what you've done with fedex
that's a nice little credible brand
there i think i'd be looking for better
delivery jobs uh for at least six months
even if you're packing in some crazy
hours maybe driving for one of the large
soda companies they tend to have they
have better hourly rates instead of you
doing door dash and i think you can make
more money
you can get some part-time jobs because
right now in the delivery game period
like so take all the trucking companies
you might even be able to drive a
smaller sized truck they are desperate
right now we've got a big shortage of
workers dave in the supply chain world
so if you like driving i'd kick the
tires is what i'm saying jason you might
be able to intended yeah yeah there it
is i stepped right into it uh but i do
think you can make more money driving
than doordash and uber or lyft yeah i
mean you've got a cdl probably and so
yeah you could probably step into some
local delivery stuff uh you know some
short-term 18-wheeler stuff or whatever
it could be north of 20-25 an hour
versus lyft and that's my point he can
make more buck for his for his time
and anything uh i i just i want you
working so many hours that your teenager
is not in the mix
for carrying the family weight
uh that uh because you you are going to
make so much more than he is yeah
unless he's unless he's doing an app
that makes two million dollars a year or
something but short of that you're gonna
you're gonna outperform out earn your
teenager and you should
uh so yeah and as much as your wife's
health allows um uh same thing
because here's the deal
ten thousand dollars extra over the next
two months
changes your life
not only do you get current you put a
thousand dollars in the bank and you
start working your way out of debt
i mean you're ten thousand dollars away
from a lot of peace
a lot more peace than you have today and
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go get
a lot of work and get ten thousand
dollars how fast can i gather up ten
thousand bucks i'm making that number up
i don't know how far behind he is but i
mean that's probably going to cover it
well i think it's a good example dave
because i think there's a lot of people
listening watching i want to encourage
you right now dave's not just throwing
this motivational speech out ten
thousand dollars is very doable in
today's economy we are looking at right
now a 3.6 unemployment rate what does it
mean to you out there who need extra
money to get that shovel bigger to get
out of debt or in this case just to get
started it actually means looking out
there and seeing there is such high
demand and you take this area the boston
massachusetts area big metropolitan area
you would be surprised how desperate
employers are to get somebody they can
count on and the money is way better
than it has ever been it's a white hot
opportunity for part-time income yeah
for 20 to 20 to 30 an hour stuff yes sir
absolutely never dreamed that that
pre-covered you would have never been
made ten dollars to it yeah not even
close yeah and that's um you know that's
that's real
real well give you an idea take walmart
national company okay just so you all
have some real numbers here they're
starting warehouse workers or people
that are stocking shelves and off hours
if you want to hustle and get after it
you can be in the 20 to 25 an hour just
doing that kind of work yes you're
exhausted and you're tired but again
what would it take to get to ten
thousand in two months i'm trying to get
current that's right get my get my back
away from the wall get the wolf away
from the door i want to put a i want to
put a bullet between the wolf's eyes i
want him to go away
and uh the wolf at the door is a it's a
scary thing man i mean i've had my
lights cut off my water cut off it's and
with little babies in the house that's
what happened to us when we went broke
30 years ago and it scares you at places
you didn't know you had
and it makes you i mean
you stand in the shower and cry because
you don't know what to do you're so
overwhelmed
and you don't have to boil the ocean
here you just got to go get some quick
money anyway that's moral and legal
fast go get you some money fast and then
you can back down and reassess your
overall career goals that's correct and
other stuff and start to maximize your
time and think where do i want to be in
10 years do i still want to be doing
this in 10 years is this company stable
are they going to continue at this level
honor you can ask all those questions
but right now go get some money that's a
great point you can't make good
long-term decisions when your head's on
fire because of the financial stress get
short-term stability excuse me
short-term stability and then we start
to plan
financial wellness and growing building
wealth like our live events we're doing
so hang up
hang on and austin will pick up and we
will get you a copy of or we'll get you
signed up for a one-year membership to
financial peace
university and that'll plug you into
every dollar the budgeting app and you
and your wife commit to doing those
lessons together there's nine
videos almost 10 million people have
been through this course and if you will
do what we teach you to do in there
while you go get some money
it'll change your whole life and uh and
then you can call up and
tell the lie and say dave you changed my
life because i won't have changed your
life you will have changed it you're
going to go get this but you're in a
perfect place
because jason because you're in that i'm
sick and tired of being sick and tired
place
i i have bottom man i said never again
never
never
again
when you say that when you yell that at
the mirror
that's when you're ready to change your
life
this is not an intellectual discussion
this is a transformational event
intellect doesn't cause transformation
emotion
does
viscerally
down inside howling at the moon never
again
will my family be in this place
when you say that then never again your
family will be in this place because
you're gonna go do what it takes to get
her done baby
and you're that kind of guy that's why
we're gonna give it to you and you call
us back and tell us how it's going this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i just gave away financial peace
university that guy who's getting ready
to get up on his feet and get going
again
you don't have to be broke to go through
fpu
you just want to learn how to handle
money better gods and grandmas ways of
handling money what does scripture say
about money live on less than you make
as an example okay and what does what do
grandma say about money live on less
than you make get out of debt stay out
of debt and we're going to show you not
only the principles but then how to
actually go about doing those things in
your life
we get it if you're worried about money
it's all consuming you wonder if you've
got enough to pay your bills you can't
afford to fill up at the gas station
nobody can it's always on your mind but
you shouldn't have to live with that
kind of stress and you don't have to
when you follow a proven plan you'll
discover peace with your money in
financial peace university you'll learn
how to learn the same plan that's helped
10 million people get on a budget save
spend wisely pay off debt become wealthy
and outrageously generous great time to
take the course we've updated a ton of
the content including george campbell dr
john delony decide today that you're
done
i've had it no more like i was talking
about before the break you can do this
go to ramseysolutions.com
fpu check out financial peace university
at ramseysolutions.com
fpu barbara's with us in minneapolis hey
barbara welcome to the ramsay show
hey papa dave and ken great to talk with
you guys thank you for all that you're
doing you too my husband and i have been
married for 10 years we have a blended
family with children ranging from the
ages of 32 down to 21.
uh there is a 21 year excuse me a 26
year old son my stepson my husband's son
uh married lives in wisconsin has five
children under the age of seven
so they're busy
um
this son has asked us over two years ago
bar asked to borrow three thousand
dollars
um my husband and i we are baby steppers
we're on baby step six
and hopefully we'll be seeing in about a
year and a half for our final deadly
screen to move us to baby step seven
um we've had a difficult time getting
the sun and daughter-in-law to pay us
back and it is causing significant
strife in the family
uh my husband and i are to the point
where we just know we're not going to
see the money again the remaining
balance of 1500 and we've accepted that
and we've moved on
um however the sun continues to just
give daggers and say that you know
we were he was entitled to the money he
deserved the money and our other adult
children see this and hear these
comments
and where i would really love your
experience ken is
the son
does not work he is not supporting his
family and then throws the emotional
manipulation to my husband and i
that we will be the ones responsible
when him and our grandchildren get
kicked out on the streets
so we're trying to determine how we just
allow these these arrows to bounce off
of us while holding the empty bag of a
financial loan um which caused a strike
between my husband and i because i did
not want to borrow the money so we've
had to solidify you i borrowed the money
to give him
i'm saying you borrowed the money to
give him
we borrowed the money that's a double
deal oh my gosh not only did he not pay
you back but you went into debt to do
this oh ouch ouch no we didn't no we did
not go into debt no we're we're in baby
steps oh you loaned him the money you
didn't borrow you loaned him the money
and now
yeah but we can't get him to work we
can't get him to maintain he can't get
him to do anything he's in a goal
no well exactly you don't get you don't
get to tell him what to do
no your bank his bank doesn't get to
tell him what to do
right
so any guidance on how we just you know
don't engage in this toxicity while
you're trying as well no absolutely
his dad needs to call him up and say the
loan is forgiven
forget it just forget it
we don't we're not gonna loan you any
money anymore ever again
but this loan's forgiven you don't know
me anymore
and i love you
i don't agree with a lot of things
you're doing but you're a grown man and
you're allowed to do those things
and um we're still gonna be friends
i'm still gonna be grandpa
and you don't owe us any more money
forget it
and if you if you want some help
uh we can give you some coaching and
we'll be your biggest cheerleaders
but we won't give you either one
coaching or cheering
without your permission
cut him loose
set him free
he is
this is bothering you
way more than it's bothering him
oh yeah you've had 28 million dollars
worth of grief he's had 20 cents worth
of grief
he hadn't got enough he had enough
character for this to bother him
well exactly yeah
so this is both barbara
barbara
let it go
it's just fifteen hundred dollars
no absolutely and what what breaks my
heart more than my pocketbook because we
don't need that much you can't make you
can't you don't your heart broken heart
didn't even matter to him
well right but it hurts my heart how he
speaks to my husband his father then
that's your husband needs to say you
can't speak to me that way anymore
yeah
okay you can only speak to me in in
tones that are reasonable i don't allow
anyone family or otherwise to speak to
me in
you know unpleasant ways in an ongoing
and ongoing process now somebody can
have a moment that's one thing okay um i
don't cut everybody out of my life that
has a moment that's not what i'm talking
about but but as an ongoing abusive
thing
that's you know you're welcome to call
here and you're welcome to be in our
home but you're gonna maintain these
levels of volume and this level of
reasonable respect and i'm going to give
you the same thing
but you know don't call here and
we're
we're not responsible for your children
they're your children
correct we love you and we're cheering
for you if you ever want any advice on
how to get where we are financially we
can show you
but but but we're not going to tell you
what to do and you're not going to make
us give you our money
you're a confused young man
and he just needs some boundaries
your husband is a nice gentle man isn't
he
he has he's he's a six foot four giant
with a big heart and a very very soft
gentle
personality
so i want your husband to roar just a
little bit
and you do too and you do too
now i want him to be mean i don't want
to be mean but it takes strength to set
boundaries
and that's what's lacking here is
boundaries and let me tell you anytime
you're someone like your your your
stepson who doesn't respect boundaries
anytime you put up a fence
and he's used to playing in your yard
he's going to have a fit
so don't expect this to go well
right it's not going to go well because
this kid's a twerp
yup okay and so all you can do is just
say you have to sit over there in your
yard and have your little fit you can't
sit in my yard and have a fit
and i just don't worry about the money
money's off the table
money's off the table and the fact that
you forgive it is not going to make this
young man suddenly have character
yeah and i think that's also one of the
hardest things for my husband too
exactly
that's amazing
it's sailed that ship sailed this is
this kid's way too old for you to fix
him
you just gotta love him where he is and
if he wants some help i can show him how
you can show him how
but until he's ready for some help it's
everybody else's fault
and bar right i would just add you need
to encourage your husband that this is
not a direct reflection on him it's very
heartbreaking when you see a kid and a
grown man make these kind of decisions
and say the things that he's saying but
i'll tell you this i i want parents to
hear this
is it's really hard when you see adult
kids do things that you didn't model for
them you didn't teach them how to do it
uh but when you see an adult kid like
this who's not working to support his
family um there's other stuff going on
there's way more going on he's not lazy
even though he presents as lazy he's
lost and you said earlier he said this
is a confused young man and i think
you're right confusion
can make a person so lost that they lose
all gumption to get out there and do
something and that's the best your
husband could be aware of to try to love
his son that way but i agree dave you
got to cut it off for a while until he
gets away from call do not loan
money do not loan money
to your kids
if you want to give them money give them
money never loan them money because you
change the relationship and that's part
of what soured this relationship
hang on we're going to send you a copy
of dr john colony's book in your past
change your future it'll help you guys
navigate this apartment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five
we needed dr john deloney for that last
call yeah um but we will tell you this
one of the things we've learned from
john and from dr henry cloud our friend
and
others in the world of uh psychology and
um
relationships psychiatry and and dealing
with all those kinds of things
i
and i'll tell you this from experience
as well one of the most difficult if not
i think the most difficult
stage of parenting
is when you can't anymore because
they're grown yeah
they get to make their own decisions
and uh and it's also the most difficult
thing of any
adult to adult relationship because you
don't get to tell the someone you love
what to do while you watch them do
something stupid or harmful or
disastrous or
whatever and so if you've got a friend
that's drinking too much you've got a
friend that's
doing something outside their marriage
they shouldn't be doing you got a friend
or a family member but you can't tell
other people what you can tell other
people what to do but they don't have to
do it yeah
and uh even though you know that what
they're doing is self-destructive and
even though it's not for selfish intent
that you're asking them to do that we're
not trying to that kid's dad at 32 years
old with five kids under seven is not
trying to do something harmful to him
but trying to get him get a job
um
take care of his family
uh but but something broke something
slipped
in that in that young man somewhere
along the line
and um
you you
a couple things that always come up in
the world of finance and even in the
world of careers as well that are over
are under the heading of what dr deloney
talks about and teaches all the time
what john talks about
is
i can't
be responsible for
nor do i have the
literal ability to make an adult do
something else i can make them wish they
did sometimes
but i can't make them do it they have to
decide to do it
and so henry cloud always says don't
don't use words like you need to because
they obviously don't need to
you should they obviously don't think
that
instead you could just say this is these
you know here's some ideas persuasion is
your only option
uh ordering people around and
and being completely torn up inside
which i have been you have been she was
watching someone yes that you love
self-destruct yeah um is a natural thing
to be but but you're doubly torn up
inside when you feel like you have the
obligation to fix it yeah well it's the
illusion of control exactly and we we so
desire to help out a friend or a family
member and you have to be able to just
live with the pain you do you just have
to be able to hurt you hurt yourself uh
you hurt for them you watch them hurt
yeah and it's terrible but the reality
is is that i think you're right dave
persuasion but you got to be careful
with persuasion you know it can only go
so far and then they begin to drown you
out you may take one or two good cracks
at it well yeah but
persuasion is fine in prayer i mean it's
um
it's god to send people into their path
that they will listen to but all of that
comes down to them making a decision why
would they make a decision to do
something differently well it can be
facts it could be emotion um it can be
influence it could be whatever but it's
it is never coercion
that's correct yeah they you like you
said a million times you you they'll
make the decision at some point or they
want to deal with the sick and tired
they're sick and tired one of the things
you learn when you're running a business
and you're leading a team you can't make
people do stuff there you cannot now
there are companies that are so stupid
they try to make people do stuff but
those are toxic environments all you can
do is create an environment to where
there are natural consequences if you
don't do it
like you don't get to work here anymore
but this is what we expect and when you
don't do this you don't get to work here
anymore and this is what we expect and
if you do do this then you know you're
not only going to get to work here
you're going to make more money you're
made in your life you're going to have a
great life you're going to be part of a
winning team you know you get to
participate in
incredible
crusade all of those things but you can
always choose
to engage in behaviors that cause you to
opt out
let me ask you a generational question
do you feel like over the last
30 50 years that the focus on safety
just in general as a culture and i'm not
being silly when i say this but bike
helmets and elbow pads you know car
seats things that we know are safe but
we didn't grow up with i just wonder if
parents have gotten to a point where
we're afraid to let our kids experience
pain maybe the one thing that can turn
their life around is that a shift or is
nothing shifted in your as you look back
oh it's probably accelerated some i mean
the helicopter parents are at a whole
new level now we have blackhawk
helicopter isn't that the truth these
were like traffic copter parents
hovercraft we have all different types
but the uh uh but it's a different thing
they're attack copters now but the uh uh
they're just loudspeakers when there's a
kid
you know yeah it's probably amped up but
it does it always comes from
all enabling
comes from a good heart
what parent
uh functional parent i'm not talking
about dysfunctional
but functional parents
always want their kids life to be better
than theirs was
and there's a point of diminishing
returns on that oh and or
also there's not only a point of
diminishing returns worse than that
we can
if we're not careful when we're enabling
with what that leads to
we can uh
misdefine
put the wrong definition of what a
better life is
a life devoid of struggle is not a
better life no
let me try that again
a life devoid
of struggle is not a better life
and so we tried to let our kids
experience pain
while they were at home under the
covering of our wings yes so that we
could control the level of pain because
when you get out
outside the home i can't help you
anymore the level of pain can become
unbearable
that's true it can put you in an
institution i mean it could be
completely overwhelming because you can
do stupid and the the the
you know it's decades
of health problems decades of brain
damage that follows that decades of
broken and torn relationships the rest
of your life yeah that are marred by
that by your i can't keep you from
making those decisions once you're
outside my so we try to let our kids you
know fall over and go okay you got to
deal with that
i'm not going to go over and fix that
conflict here's how you deal with
conflict go work on that and they would
do it wrong sometimes oh sure and but
all within so a life devoid of struggle
is not necessarily a better life and
when you as a parent
and that's a little bit of the bike
helmet thing you know the thing is we
want there to be a hundred percent
zero fatalities 100 zero whatever but
that means that no kids ever jumped over
anything on their bicycle yeah
and that would be a shame yeah
it would be a shame yeah it's also a
shame when one of them gets hurt i was
hurt i get stitches all over my body
doing that crap
and i'm not do you know i'm not i don't
want children to be harmed i'm not that
stupid right but this idea that you can
completely remove
um
all risk from life and still have a high
quality life yeah i just jumped out of
an airplane the other day yes you did i
watched it i watched you float down you
watched me from the ground you didn't i
wasn't ready folks
i i need to hey i need to babystep my
way there was nothing you know you
should have seen the plane he would have
been well and you can't you can't say
stuff like he left it all on the ground
no you left it all on the field you
can't say lines like that no you can't
you know one thing
we've gotten to a point where we are not
even trying to just eliminate pain for
our kids dave now we're trying to
eliminate unpleasantness yeah and so now
it's all about i want my kid to feel
this you need a safe space when you're
triggered and all this ridiculous stuff
if it's all about making our kids feel
good we'll miss the part of going off to
college
with tenured professors
they're not reasonable human beings no
and so
by and large yeah and so uh you know
it's but now it's all about junior
getting out without a single
ever having his little feelings hurt or
his ideas if i actually disagree with
you it completely shuts some of you down
yeah you can't deal with it
because you've had zero conflict ever in
your life to process right you got to do
you know so your critical thinking
skills are mush i wish we had some data
on how quickly uh my generation learned
to ride a bike versus the kids of today
because here's the deal if you wrecked
when when i was a kid you stuck to the
sheets for a week you know now they got
more pads on them than you could
well it makes the point doesn't it i
don't remember sticking to the sheets no
skin on your knees
oh yeah if you wrecked a bike in my hand
yeah i know but kind of leaking back in
my day
oh my god you sound like that guy this
is the guy who used to say get up spray
some bacteria on it
[Music]
you're the one that used to say that
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships we're glad you're here ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we talk about your life your career
your money
your relationships the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five stacy's in austin texas hi stacy
how are you
hi can you all hear me okay sure what's
up
great um thanks so much for taking my
call i really enjoy listening to both of
you i feel like i'm having a fangirl
moment so
um
okay so
the simple question is
we have we had a wake-up call in july
and or actually june
and we've tallied everything and we
started we're on baby step two it is
just a really daunting number
um without our mortgage we own a home
without our mortgage we have a hundred
and seventy thousand dollars in debt
that's
you name it mostly credit cards and
student loans and some car payments and
how much do you owe on your cars
uh i owe 15 000 on mine my monthly
payment is 260. my husband owes 31 000
on his and his car payment is 600.
i recently sold a much bigger more
expensive car and downsized but was
afraid to pay all cash for it
um
so i cut my money that was before you
had the wake-up call
well kind of the beginning of it and
then
it's a family car we have a
four-year-old son um
and
i just was like gosh we put the most
miles on my car so i just wanted it to
be something really reliable and safe
and
um what are your two cars just tell me
what the two models are in year
sure i have a 2011 um
lexus rx350 that's the 260 a month
and my husband drives a huh
dave i'm interested if you'll know this
one it's a 2014 chevy ss but it has a
hennessey supercharger in it oh yeah
and it's recently been retuned and it's
a it's a beast anyways those are our two
cars great gas mileage not uh yeah
all right so what's your household
income
um
we make over 200 000 we net 12 000 a
month um
i i have a nice base salary but also
earn commissions so that's our low end
and some months we make more than that
my husband's salary is set and he's an
i.t
okay so we have a big shovel we're just
so your questions what
well
so i hate the amount of debt we have um
85 000 a year for two years and you're
out of debt
that's
i could do it i don't know if my
husband's
you know wanting to sacrifice so
ultimately
ultimately we're not in the home that we
want to be in forever we do want to move
to the northeast it's just a dream that
we've had
so
you know what the problem with that is
what you're going to go with you go in
the northeast yeah i know you're going
to go with you
and your husband who doesn't want to
sacrifice is going to go with you
yeah
you can't run from this
yeah the two the two of you in your
relationship and you the two of you as a
team have to stare this beast down
yeah and the beast is in your mirror
yeah you don't have a math problem you
got a me problem
yep
so that's where we start
and when
when the two of you call me back and say
we are truly sick and tired of being
sick and tired we're not gonna
rationalize about a freaking
four-year-old needing a car to ride in
that's a certain kind of car called a
lexus
we're not going to rationalize about
driving a muscle car when we're like a
grown man with children and can't pay
his bills we're not going to rationalize
and run to the northeast and pay all
this off with the equity from our home
and never have faced the fact that we
wouldn't pay a price to win in the
mirror you guys when you're ready to do
that you're ready to do anything you're
not you don't have to do any of these
things mathematically you can keep the
cars
but you can't keep the lifestyle and you
can't keep the wishy-washy i sort of
kind of want to do this stuff
not and get out of debt yeah not get out
of that
there's only one way you're going to get
out of debt is you guys have substantial
change in your view of money your view
of stuff your due of acquisition your
due of what gives you peace your view of
those things when you change those
things that's transformation
and you this debt will just evaporate in
two years when you do that
you'll be on my stage in here screaming
i'm debt-free
i'd love to be stacy let me ask you a
quick question couple of credit cards
what's your monthly payments your
minimums that you're paying on these
credit cards give me a couple i'm just i
broke our debt down because i'm i'm the
geek um so
the consumer debt is 94 000 and we pay 2
000 a month on just consumer debt um i
called consumer debt everything but the
cars and his student loans and by the
way it's all consumer yeah it's all i
get i get you this is just how i broke
it down i really so
here's what you need to hear you guys
need to say this to each other out loud
we make
thousand dollars a year
and we couldn't even choose to live on
that
i know that's what we're gonna call our
natural credit card deck we don't change
yeah you're gonna be bankrupt you're
gonna be the bankrupt rich people
the reason i ask you this question stacy
is because you started off the call
going it feels insurmountable but if you
were to just fix the car situation
that's 860 bucks a month a couple of
credit cards you're quickly over a
thousand dollars a month it would be
free
to then put towards the student loans
and with your income what dave is saying
you could get out of this thing quick i
just don't know that you believe that
you guys can get out of this as quick as
we believe you can well 200 minus 85 is
not a bad mile to live on that's 115.
i know
yeah
not counting taxes but still i mean it's
still that's the big numbers but you
guys
i don't think my husband's willing to do
that but my husband is willing to move
to the northeast sell the house and pay
off all the debt with that with the
with the uh windfall you get from
selling a house in this world that we
live in today because he's going to make
a ton of money you can do that if you
want to do it but i predict this will
crop back up because you've never dealt
with you
he's never dealt with him and as a
couple we've never dealt with we need a
common vision for our home
the people with our last name
as for me and my house
we need a common vision and you all
don't have that your only common vision
is you spend like you're in congress
and it's killing you girl you're
breaking my heart
so
i that's my challenge to y'all
lovingly as kindly as i can
be not conformed to this world
but be transformed
by the renewing
of your mind live like no one else so
that later you can live and give
like no one else no discipline seems
pleasant at the time
but it yields
a harvest
of righteousness
this is what's in your future one way or
the other
you're either going to decide or
somebody's going to decide for you later
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
right now you're hearing a lot of
talking heads in the news stirring up
fear about the real estate market if you
believe them then you think the housing
market's going to crash
and it will be a repeat repeat of the
2008 crisis you're not hearing the truth
and you can't make decisions based on
fear you need actual facts here they are
in 2008 there was a huge supply of homes
but not enough buyer demand three times
almost four times more homes were on the
market in 2008 than are on the market
today
and buyer demand was much
lower
than it is now
our demand is way up
there's 12 million more households than
there were and there's 5 million more
millennials in their mid-30s than there
were gen xers in their mid-30s in 2008
and mid-30s people are their prime house
buying time
so demand is up supply is down house
prices aren't going to crash
right now there's half as many homes for
sale as there are twice the buyers
half as many for sale you don't have a
housing
crash when half as many homes are for
sales there are buyers
buyers are fighting to get houses still
slowing down there's not an auction like
it was in a lot of areas but it's slowed
down you got to work with an experienced
real estate agent when you're in a
market like this this is not amateur
hour
and so jump onto ramseysolutions.com
find the people that we endorse elps
endorsed local providers that are ramsey
trusted agents in your area to buy or to
sell in this current world it's too wild
out there to go on your own you need a
pro in your corner walking with you they
don't cost you money they make you money
because the deals are much better when
you're dealing with an experienced
high octane high protein real estate
agent check on our ramsey trusted elps
at ramsey solutions.com if you're doing
a real estate deal and you should be
doing real estate deals katie is in
springfield hi katie welcome to the
ramsey show
hello can you hear me thank you for
having me sure what's up
so i am a newlywed college student and
my husband and i
are about 12 000 a little bit over in
debt and are trying to figure out how to
get
ahead of this ball before it gets bigger
than what we can pay off reasonably
right after school
your twelve thousand dollars in debt
yes and you're what you're in school
um so i have full red and i'm finishing
my associates my husband has also
finished his associates but he's
finishing his bachelor's in
and how are we paying for all of this
future education
uh so right now we're working and we
have scholarship and then all of my
leftover scholarship since i'm at a
really cheap community college goes over
to his bills for school so you're not
adding any more debt
so that's what we're trying to avoid is
adding any more debts that's what i was
asking about we've loaned options but we
don't want to take them if we don't have
to you don't have to don't take them
you need to you need to draw a line in
the sound and say no more debt
so that's the first thing and then once
you do that then twelve thousand dollars
you can knock out you may have to wait
till you graduate and get jobs to be
able to knock it out but your first goal
is not getting rid of the 12 000 your
first goal is graduate without any more
debt
and so i would just pile up money until
he graduates
and i'd pay off the 12 000 after he gets
out of school
okay
yeah because right now getting both of
you through with no more debt is a big
job in and of itself isn't it
yes that's enough to concentrate on and
i think that's a great goal and i think
it's very doable by the way
but you do have to take what we say take
debt off the table
if you go that's not an option i'm not
going to do that now how are we going to
figure it out and then that means
scholarships and all the stuff you've
been doing you've been scratching and
clawing and scraping and scrapping and
hustling and grinding and you're doing
all the right stuff you're doing a lot
of smart things here
but the only thing i would tell you is a
take debt off the table b
um
you're if you if you can simply graduate
with no debt
no more debt and deal with the 12 000
later i'm gonna call that a success
wouldn't you i would because again i
think we've been illustrating this hour
certainly that you can pay off twelve
thousand dollars certainly two people
together in this job economy you can
knock that out so fast it really make
your head spin how quickly you can knock
that out i might get that as a signing
bonus at the new job mike that's right
especially with that engineering degree
who knows i mean yeah they're both going
to make good money
here's what's interesting in north
america today
there are legitimate
areas of poverty where people literally
have
unbelievable poverty
um
nowhere near what there used to be
it's the best it's ever been the poverty
level is the is the lowest it's ever
been in american history right now
and uh but aside from someone living at
that
personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
none of you listening really have a math
problem
as much as you have a behavior problem
and that includes me
when i discovered this truth years ago i
figured out if i could get the guy in
the mirror to behave he could be skinny
and rich
but he's got issues with donuts
chocolate covered preferably yeah he's
got other
issues with other kinds of foods pizza
yeah yeah
it could it could be a problem oh yeah
and you know we all have this issue of
you know denying ourselves something now
to get something better later yeah
this idea of delayed pleasure which is a
grown-up act children do what feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it
and so
you know our caller before the break 200
000 a year 85 thousand dollars in income
that's a fairly easy math formula you
should be out of debt in two years but
you have to be willing to deeply
sacrifice and oh by the way they've been
living not on two hundred thousand
they've been living on about 250 000
because they've run up over a hundred
thousand dollars with a credit card debt
and so um
not only do you have to cut your
lifestyle down to your income
now you have to cut it dramatically
below your income
none of that is a math problem that's
all just a decision
the rationalizations the beliefs that
we've brought in as to what is normal
and our level of work ethic
how much are we willing to work short
term and long term
and am i willing to stay at a job that
quote unquote feels secure
when there's something i can make twice
as much with a reasonable level of risk
yeah well you're really hitting on
something i say this all the time dave
that we are as humans
our natural human condition is to be
more comfortable being miserable than
comfortable
and miserable being comfortable right
it's like well we would rather be
miserable than uncomfortable is a better
way to say it yeah because like i know
what my misery is well
i know yeah i got the credit card
payments we're barely making ends meet
but we got all the stuff and it's
killing me but i'm used to it versus
what would it take to actually pay off
85 000 what would it take how quickly
could we do it and we don't even dive
into that question
and so what happens is dave the unknown
is terrifying it is absolutely paralyzed
like walking in a cave you were you and
uh you and uh daniel ramsey were telling
me the other day a story about being in
israel in some cave or something where
it finally wigged you out because it was
so like dark or something or so crazy
crowded the people wouldn't get out of
there always crouch
but if you've ever been in a dark cave
where you can't see in front of you yeah
you you don't move i can handle that as
long as i got a light yeah i mean no i'm
saying but imagine how terrifying here's
an example it's overwhelming well yeah
but you get in a
deep fog what do you do you pull the car
over immediately you can't see behind
the hood of your car
you are out of control
and you can't see your way towards
control it cause it's called anxiety
right that's what we call it but part of
this is we don't even look into what
would be what would have to be true for
us to do this and then when we dive into
the unknown a little bit and get some
answers now what was terrifying and
intimidating is oh all right it's gonna
be hard but it's doable yeah
uh jim collins the rope the book good to
great talks about that and great by
choice yeah uh he said the thing that
that
paralyzes more people in business and
it's true in your personal life too
people are more afraid of ambivalence
than they are known struggle absolutely
right they'll choose known struggle over
not knowing yes
quicker and so that's what we do here we
shine a light of knowing and go you can
do this now now you got to face the most
difficult equation of all the human
equation you personal finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 of knowledge it is
truly up to
you it's not up to the white house it's
up to what happens in your house
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage chris and caitlin
are with us hey guys how are you hi hey
how are you good to have you guys where
do you live uh we are from a small town
in ohio belleville okay what's that near
um it's about 20 minutes south of
mansfield got it okay cool welcome to
nashville and how much debt did you guys
pay off we paid off fifty six thousand
eighty one dollars and seventy cents in
17 months way to go and your range of
income during that time uh we pretty
much stayed right about 90 k cool what
do y'all do for a living
i do quality control for a
pharmaceutical company
and i own and operate a construction
business with my brother excellent very
cool very cool what kind of debt was the
56 000
a little bit of everything dave we had
student loans uh
a truck payment tractor payment uh
credit cards medical
you you name it we had it what was the
biggest debt uh student loans okay how
much was that
right around
to 25 okay so almost half of it was
student loan debt yes sir who did that
ah
all right caitlin all right cool because
he did the truck and the tractor so
we know what happened there right i
doubt neither one of those were you
all right good so it sounds like we're
about even here how long y'all been
married uh just two years we're going on
two years okay so just shortly after
marriage you come home and you say
we're gonna get out of debt tell us how
that happened and how you got connected
to us yeah so
really i think she came home and she
said uh you know i heard of this guy
dave ramsey and i said okay who is that
we just got married i don't hear about
another guy right
so she continued on saying well let just
take a chance listen to his podcast hear
him out and and i did and and we were
already so broke at the time i said we
have nothing else to lose let's let's
try it
why not yeah why not we're not going
anywhere but down
might as well give old ramsey a shot
that's great i like it so what was the
first thing you did after that
started paying off the credit cards
stopped using the credit cards so you
got you got a game plan together you
said we're gonna work the baby steps
yeah yep and did the debt snowball and
the little littlest was the credit card
yep okay good it was just a force to be
reckoned with from there it just kept
tumbling and tumbling okay so once you
saw it happen and then and it's game on
you know then it starts
what was the craziest sacrifice you did
to get out
i think where people kind of rolled
their eyes at you yeah i think uh you
know it's one of those things where you
got to keep your nose on the grindstone
keep pushing because you're going to hit
a point where you're like man is this
really
this is tough and you know that's where
the teamwork comes into play
and you know without caitlyn we couldn't
did this without her so and i was out
eight nine not getting home till
sometimes ten o'clock at night trying to
sell jobs and hanging drywall hanging
drop you name it just out there hustling
trying to trying to get this paid off
yeah just whatever it took right
whatever it took all the way through was
that outside of your company with your
brother you're doing handyman any kind
of odd construction job you could find
nope pretty much yeah yeah wow good for
you guys how's it feel to be free
amazing
feels great who were your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
i think honestly uh it'd be my younger
brother and sister autumn aiden they've
been uh with this journey from from
before the beginning
they were a reason why they were our
first reason why at 19 years old get a
phone call
i go pick my brother and sister up and
we didn't know what that was going to
turn into but i think it's the greatest
thing that happened to the both of us it
turned us into mature adults at a very
young age
we ended up taking over custody of them
oh wow and they were right around 10 and
14 at the time
uh and we were 19. we were 19. so whoa
so we have two kids here now uh
we're like what the heck do we do
and we're broke
two kids don't know what to do we're
broke so
we gotta we gotta figure out a game plan
we gotta figure out something fast
because you look at you look at the
generations before you
and the generation's growing up with you
and you say
is this what i want and if the answer is
no then you got to do something about it
you got to make the change
and create your own destiny yeah so when
you're wearing shirts say change our
family tree it means a lot means a lot
yeah because you've really have stepped
had to step into a broken situation and
and and man up at a very very early age
i'm so proud of you guys you're amazing
people
amazing people and along the way you had
a baby we did
all right and so how old's a baby she's
11 months now awesome and what's her
name reagan rose okay and she's got some
built-in babysitters
they do a great job
that's great that's awesome
very very cool well i you know i gotta
ask you know you're you're in the midst
of you know a life-changing relational
situation and then you decide okay we're
gonna make some life changes financially
was there a point where it got to be
like this is so overwhelming how are we
going to do this i see you're shaking
your head take us there um i think when
we were eating
um
what's that dollar dinner hamburger
helper three times a week and
the electric got shut off because
somebody didn't pay it that was pretty
stressful
and um kids always need food always need
clothes always want to do stuff and
we were we were the ones there we so
that was really that i had it moment
when we didn't have any money we didn't
have anything
there's nothing left over for us and you
guys are how old now 24. wow
wow it's pretty powerful stuff when
you're 34 where you're going to be
sitting it's going to be amazing
and uh though
the honor and the nobility that you have
shown in your life overall for your
whole family uh is
it's breathtaking and number one but
number two where that's going to take
you to
if you continue to live your life with
that kind of character
where you're going to go is going to be
amazing
i mean just this little bit of 56
dollars where the debt is a big hurdle
but it ain't nothing compared to what's
coming your future's so bright it's
unbelievable yeah i want i want you all
to know that the strength
that you have acquired during the
struggle i don't even think we can
possibly define it i don't even know if
you know how strong you all really are
now with what you've had to overcome
it's truly uh inspiring it really is
well done y'all you're amazing we're so
proud of you thank you proud to know you
very well done very very well done what
advice do you have for somebody trying
to get out of debt you did it
i think uh
faith where we think we think it's faith
and commitment number one faith in god
and then faith in each other and then
faith in
in in your budget and stay committed to
your budget and stay committed to one
another
and if you can do that you can do
anything amen
amen what about you caitlin what do you
tell people the secret is
i would definitely say the same thing
i'd also say even when you don't like
the budget the budget is there to help
you yeah that's right that's i agree
with that one agree with that one very
well done all right let's get the whole
gang up here the new baby the brothers
and sisters that are now part of the
family
everything this is a family tree that
has been changed by so much but most of
all by the incredible character and
nobility this young couple very very
well done oh she's so cute
oh my gosh unbelievable
beautiful beautiful beautiful all right
it's chris and caitlin autumn aidan and
reagan from ohio what an incredible
story 56 000 paid off in 17 months
making 90 000. we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires total money makeover
and financial peace for you to say we're
proud of you and to take you into the
next part of the journey count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
one
two
three we're
free
yeah
wow
[Music]
wow
you're 19 years old and you take custody
of your 10 year old
little brother yeah and your little
sister unbelievable
and then we get married to have a baby
and let's get out of debt oh there we go
while we're at it oh my gosh that's just
enough to take it on
and um
but this is the this is uh this is how
lives are changed
when people like that step up
and um you don't have to be 104 and you
don't have to have a phd and you don't
have to have a million dollars you just
got to have character man that's
impressive
this
is the ramsey chef
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today philippians 3 14 i
press on toward the goal for the prize
of the upward call of god
in christ jesus
bruce lee said the successful warrior is
the average man with laser-like focus
well we just see that every day here on
the show that one i like that one a lot
trevor is with us trevor is in grand
rapids michigan hi trevor how are you
hi david ken how are you guys great man
how can we help
good
hey i have a career question
i guess it's kind of a good problem to
have i think um a few weeks ago i was
um
in the interview process for um two
different roles
and um
kind of i guess company a we went
through the process
and
they sent me an offer and so
i followed up with company b
and only to find out that the hiring
manager had resigned from his position
so
i'm a christian so i kind of saw that as
kind of one door closing another one
opening
and i accepted the offer to the first
company um
well about a week later the leadership
from company b
um contacted me and asked if he could
send over an offer
so kind of the predicament i'm in now is
i have two offers but i've already
accepted
one offer from another company so
i'm just struggling ethically kind of
how to handle that situation um and so i
just wanted to call you guys for some
reason on that sure so what's the better
offer for you clearly be
um
i think so yeah i think otherwise
there'd be no struggle yeah there's no
struggle so yeah right so here's what
you have to weigh um your your morality
you're a really good guy you're a high
character guy so you feel bad about this
because you want to take b
but you're worried about
how they're going to feel and maybe a
little bit more worried about how you're
going to look if you go back to a and go
hey listen i accepted the offer i was up
for two offers at the time here's what
happened
um and i think you have to say how would
you want someone to handle this
situation with you uh and so here let me
give you what i think is the the real
issue you have to get comfortable with
if you take a in other words if you stay
with a but you really want b and b is
the better offer
um you're really doing a a disservice if
you stay anyway so what you think feels
like well i accepted the offer i've got
to be a good guy i've got to be high
character and i got to stay with a but
your eye is always on b i think it's due
to disservice to company a anyway so i
think the way to handle this the way i
would handle it is is to treat someone
the way i would want to be treated in
this situation which is be absolutely
clear and front about what happened the
timeline and everything they're not
going to be happy about it but you got
to do what you believe is right for you
long term what's the difference in the
offers
uh uh about fifteen thousand dollars a
year what about the companies
um
so one company's uh company a is a
little more established um and has a
little bit more um structure so i kind
of know what i'm gonna need to into
company b is a little more
uh it's smaller and it's it's got
they're going through a lot of changes
there's a lot of opportunity a lot of
eyeballs on the roll yeah they're also
very disorganized
probably no they are you told me the
hiring manager got quit or got fired and
they never followed up to you with you
until you'd already accepted another
offer
you're exactly right they had no handoff
they had no methodology for handing off
a lost employee and picking up their
workload they're disorganized
that's true
and so they're more of a startup and
they're flying by the sea of their pants
which one are you going to exist better
in
i might be better than the startup
because i'm kind of that rough and
tumble guy but some people some people
prefer the structure and the
predictability
yeah and i'm coming from a larger kind
of publicly traded company so i'm i'm
used to that a little bit more so what's
what's most attractive about b is it
just the fifteen thousand dollar bump or
is there more to it than that
well well that's that's certainly a part
of it um well is it the majority part
because i'm telling you uh for 15k i'm
not doing it yeah for 15k that'll wear
off pretty quickly
if you if you see this as an opportunity
i'm not as uh dave brings a very good
point but i'd want to know is this a
isolated situation or is this a pattern
across the board with how they handle
the miscommunication
you know what i'm saying so
a is it a pattern and b are you mostly
attracted to b just because of the bump
it it would i'm a pretty rough and
tumble ready to go with a startup but it
would concern me
if
that they dropped a ball and the ball by
the way was you
that would concern me yes yes as long as
it could be isolated i could see this
happening
so i want you i want to put you on the
spot you didn't answer it yet is it
mostly the pay or is this you feel like
this might be a good ladder for you to
climb
um
i you know i'm trying to reconcile that
right now as we talk um i think the pay
has something to do with it but i think
there's there's definitely opportunity
at both both places so as far as the
matter to climb like i think there's
opportunity at both places that's fair
what's the total pay
um
for the
well for which one uh the total i mean
either one 15 or minus 50.
so the the higher pay is 125.
okay so 125 or 110.
sure yeah so we're talking about a 15
swing give or take 14 swing
yeah yeah so um well i i would be
perfectly fine
with either choice if i were you if you
want to walk into the other people and
go look here's what happened
i don't like this i don't even like how
it feels this is awkward i'm very sorry
i'm going the other direction and take b
okay um but i i will throw into the mix
just as a part of the decision that i
don't think this is apples to apples
you're presenting this as apples to
apples plus or minus 15. and i think b
is a lot more unpredictable
and i i don't single events don't bother
me but if you can establish that this
this is a pattern
and this is the this organization just
simply does not run as well for whatever
reason and
that discounts it for me
okay and so i yeah
you you can decide that you can impress
i'm sorry
okay i was saying this is super fresh it
just happened kind of this morning and
so it's uh it's something that i that's
the type of stuff that i want to i
wanted to call you guys and like
think about things that i wasn't already
thinking how many employees is b
[Music]
and how old are they
five years old
okay same industry or different
industries
um
different industries all right that's
another question that i didn't bring up
i mean long term what do you want to do
for a living do you want to pivot to the
industry of of company b
well i mean
i should i should prefer this i'm i'm in
finance so this is like a senior finance
role so it's uh it'll be financing both
in both
okay just a different same type of work
different industry
yeah same type of work but yeah i think
dave's really uh on to something here
fifteen thousand dollars is not a
decision that i would make for the short
term i would go long term
long what's the right long-term decision
now which one's gonna make you the most
happy that's finance you're a very
structured guy you're a methodical
process driven guy
if there's chaos at that other place
it's going to drive you nuts you need to
really know that before you make this
call
and um it's not worth the 15 bump if
it's going to drive you nuts
and then that takes the problem off the
table obviously i'm not sure that's the
case i'm just questioning how this whole
thing went down if that was the way you
ended up interacting with your
leadership team for the next five years
you're going to pull your hair out
that's right
if it's if it's if if that's what it is
now we've got a little of both around
here honestly we've got some areas of
this company that are still very raw
very frontier very pioneering very rough
and tumble and very disorganized and
chaotic and then we've got other areas
of this place that are running like a
freaking sewing machine there's the
processors are so dialed in and so
professional and we got 1200 team
members
so we got a little of both going on
around here so we could get accused of
either
um
it's not saying that company is right or
wrong i'm just i'm just trying to make
observations about how this guy fits and
where he goes in the thing here so
um
yeah but but
uh uh
the way to handle it if you chose to do
b is simply just be up front and tell
the truth yeah all the way through do it
the way you'd want somebody to handle
you treat other people like you're gonna
be treated yeah solves all your business
ethics problems be classy here's why
dave this is relevant to this last call
i shared an article today on the show uh
the ken coleman show 30 of people who
changed jobs in the last two years are
regretting it
30 they took the paycheck and then they
said it wasn't as good as we thought it
was going to be or i missed my old
company i miss them
so you got to be careful making these
kind of moves just for a paypal it's got
to be a long term play yeah it'll be
where you need to be good good point
well that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books thanks to austin ben
zack andrew james kelly
everybody will everybody in the booth
again good show we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the ramsey
network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
you